congressman eric swalwell filed a
lawsuit against donald trump
claiming that he incited the capital
riot on jan 6.
also named in the suit as my next guest
alabama congressman mo brooks who
swallowed says
has been m.i.a for months now svalball
even hired a private
investigator to find him now this week
it came to a head when congressman
brook's wife martha was accosted
now look at this video congressman's
wife pulls into their garage
seconds later a car speeds up the
driveway
a man jumps out and runs into that same
garage attached by the way to their
private home
the man was in there for about 15
seconds until brooks's wife chased him
out
we now know what that man was there for
he was a process server joining me now
congressman mo brooks congressman um
your message tonight to eric swalwell he
wanted to serve you and your wife or
you and your wife accepted i guess on
your behalf
um but they'll say that's just what an
aggressive process server does
well i'm a little bit baffled by eric
swalwell's conduct in a variety of
respects first and foremost
this is a frivolous politically
motivated lawsuit
there is no liability on the part of
myself or president trump
although i pray proudly stand with
president trump as we defend
this frivolous litigation but second for
three months two months since the
lawsuit was filed back in march
eric swalwell has gotten notice of when
we're going to go vote
roughly a hundred different times he
could have had me served as i'm walking
to or from
the capitol the house floor where i vote
in my house office building
but he chose not to instead the swalwell
team chose to hire a process server
that would chase my wife down as she's
coming home
from church keeping in mind that she's a
grandmother with 10 grandchildren
there could have been some of those
grandchildren in the car with her when
this transpired
and then illegally entered my home now
in alabama
this is a criminal offense it's a
trespass in the first degree
and it carries a penalty up to one year
and a six thousand dollar fine
so they did it entirely the wrong way
eric swalwell should have been a man
about it
he served me on a number of occasions in
washington
when he had that opportunity but instead
he took the dishonorable path
and went after my wife uh well this is
what swalwell's attorney said about you
not wanting to be a part of this lawsuit
mo brooks had a lot to say when he was
standing in front of a pro-trump crowd
pumping them up to go storm the capitol
and when it became clear that there are
legal consequences for doing that he
wasn't interested in being a part of it
congressman was that your message on
january 6 did you incite a
riot at the capitol only about 20
absolutely not and with respect to eric
swalwell let me emphasize this
i have gone through the complaint there
are at least 50 occasions that i have
identified i'm sure there are a lot more
but i readily identify their flat out
lies
their deceit in these allegations and
there's going to be
zero evidence to support it much like
there was zero evidence to support the
two years
of russian collusion allegations by eric
swalwell
and others not counting the sham
impeachment efforts
by eric swalwell and others that's what
we're looking at unfortunately in
washington dc fascinating developments
maybe we should have asked the chinese
agent about them
swallow would have answered that hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else